I've got a pen and I've got a phone the
words with which chief executive Barack
Obama describes how he unilaterally
circumvents the rightly deliberative
legislative bodies of these United
States when they act too slowly or when
they block his initiatives all together
through a blatant overextension of
executive order he takes matters into
his own hands now today we shall examine
that thing with which our current
executive campaigns so successfully in
2008 change specifically we shall see
how placing more and more power directly
in the hands of the people can actually
lead to a tip in the balance of power
toward the executive branch ladies and
gentlemen it's at this juncture that I
respectfully rely upon your own
experience and upon your own devoted
study of our nation's founding documents
to recognize the abuse of executive
order and the fact that in just six
years
our current executive is pushed forward
twice as many executive orders then did
our first 15 presidents in a combined 70
years of administration and because you
already recognize that this greatly
deviates from the way our country was
originally constituted we shall not
dwell on this unconstitutional shift in
the balance of power toward the
executive itself but rather how
democratization was one factor that made
that change possible indeed after we
consider Plato's critique of Taraka and
democracy our country wasn't founded as
a democracy at all and finally a look at
democratization within the 20th century
we shall see that the deterioration of a
check upon the people enabled the
executive branch to overstep their
original powers enumerated within the
United States Constitution book eight of
Plato's Republic focuses on the idea of
change within a regime first Plato
outlines what the best regime is
then he describes exactly what changes
are required for that just regime to be
degraded to the point where one man
rules alone now within this hypothetical
just regime proper ordering is the key
in Plato describes three classes the
guardians are characterized by wisdom
the Warriors by a kind of courage and
finally the artisans are the great mass
of the people by a kind of desire now
properly wisdom ought to guide
decision-making and preserving courage
ought to sustain wisdoms guidance of the
body politic and if these two conditions
are met then the great mass of the
people with moderation
can then even do things like participate
in government but checked by wisdom but
as a deviation from this paradigm Plato
decries how democracy removes wisdom
preserving courage and the popular
passion of the people from their proper
ordering and places them all upon an
equal level and here no longer does
wisdom rule but instead the passions of
the people that he describes that in
this state that's sort of chaos ensues
and here the people themselves are prone
to prop up a single man a man of the
people to establish order into the
constantly changing laws driven by the
people's own constantly changing desires
this man of the people
democratically elected working through
the power of the people at first
promises things like the eradication of
economic inequality but he uses his
position to actually consolidate power
into his own hands to the point where
all he needs to rule is just a pen and a
phone Plato recognized in his own day
that democracy can lead directly to an
over extension of executive power now
thankfully here in America our
government structures do not yet fully
resemble Plato's account of democracy
however his warning does bear careful
consideration in view
the fact that we are currently adopting
more and more democratic features within
our government originally our country
was founded as a constitutional republic
direct democracy and our founding we the
people ourselves recognize the need for
checks and balances upon political power
and even upon we ourselves using Plato's
paradigm of a just regime its wisdom and
structure that provides for the liberty
of the people preserving courage the
tension between the branches of
government resisting encroachment that
courage preserves this structure and
within it we the people ourselves find
expression through popular bodies like
the House of Representatives
now when James Madison wrote Felder's
Papers 62 and 63 he was conscious of
Plato's warning he saw that the
ever-changing desires of the people if
admitted into government can create
instability within the text of those
documents
he cited Plato's examples of the dangers
of mutable Athenian democracy and it is
for this reason that the Senate was
instituted to be that more deliberative
body that resists the propensity of all
numerous assemblies to yield to the
impulses of sudden and violent passions
but the key to the efficacy of this
check on the people was the fact that
the people themselves did not elect
senators but rather state legislators
did however a wave of popular change
swept this check aside in 1913
progressive legislators enacted the 17th
amendment to the Constitution now
providing for the direct election of
senators and there were no minced words
about what this change was for in fact
in 1915 progressive Herbert Crowley
proclaimed that the machinery of direct
democracy had come the marketization had
come he further explained that pure
democracy was now both natural and
appropriate
and following this change a shift toward
power to the people immediately we see
an actual consolidation of government
powers within the hands of a single
executive indeed men of the people like
Franklin Roosevelt arose to impose order
on confused events like our own Great
Depression but he did this by means of
no less than three thousand five hundred
twenty two executive orders and
following upon these executive orders we
see the consolidation of government
powers into the hands of 38 newly
created federal executive regulatory
agencies and now when Roosevelt spoke up
on American democracy he asserted that
fundamentally a great and strong group
of central institutions guided by a
small number of men that could best
direct government he describes the
reason for this change in his Democratic
convention address he explains that the
adoption of democracy had come to aid
those overtaken by disaster that's
exactly what Plato warned this man if
the people would promise and just as
Plato warned this man actually
consolidated government power into his
own hands a ladies and gentlemen I asked
you to recall that quote that I recited
from our current executive just a few
moments ago Barack Obama went on to
explain that the reason that he
circumvented our legislative bodies and
made laws by means of his pen and his
phone was to make sure Americans are
getting the kind of help that they need
that's exactly the rhetoric that Plato
warned us this man of the people would
have that's exactly the same rhetoric
that accompanied democratization in the
20th century and the subsequent
consolidation of power within the
hansman executive but I also urge you to
consider that principle of change which
has pervaded our discussion and it
doesn't just go one way we can once
again look to the warning plate we can
once again look to the wisdom in
structure provided by our founders in
our constitution and we can return to a
state where
one man holds the King like powers of
the pen or of the phone